when you've been married this long don't
touch me okay what's one food David I
would absolutely never eat
[Music]
wow couple's quiz couple quit
hi I'm Neil Patrick Harris hi I'm David
Burtka and we're doing the GQ couples
quiz let's try that again
David
describe our first date oh bonus if you
can remember what I wore it was a long
day we first went to the coffee shop
that's now at like a Chase Bank yeah in
Union Square then we went to a movie
Taking Lives yeah we did and then we
went to dinner at 44 and 10 and you
ordered the chicken waffles it was like
your thing to wear Abercrombie and Fitch
and baggy jeans and I worked on that
wrong
just kidding
what is the best way to make me laugh to
say
that you you are gonna only buy no
inexpensive clothes
what is my favorite gift you've given me
I have to say your 40th birthday 40th
birthday scavenger hunt Extravaganza
Across America started with a surprise
party in Los Angeles and we went
cross-country picking up Clues and gifts
and experiences to New York with another
surprise birthday party week long week
long epic took me a year to produce and
it was then I finally said I I would
love you well why don't you show it
next question this this is easy okay
what made me want to become a chef the
sudden passing of your mother that's
true making you realize that life is too
short you gotta do stuff that you want
to do yeah it was a great call yeah
thanks buddy
what's my best party trick there's so
many to choose from there is so many to
choose from I'd say either your Bent
Fork you can bend a fork with your mind
true or you can make things disappear
like wrong juggling I can juggle oh I've
never seen you juggle on a party it's a
great party trick you should see it
sometime kills oh
you've never seen me do this I'm not at
a party wait where'd that one come out
of my ass literally yeah right on the
beach if you said it was your Beach
trick but never had a party oh
Hallelujah
okay
thanks so much
someone's gotta clean that up get to
work what is my least favorite part of
working together the last time we worked
together was on on uncoupled season one
and I would guess that the least
favorite we never had scenes together I
would guess that the least favorite
thing was that I had a big like giant
trailer and you were given like one we
didn't even work together on that day so
what's the answer notes you're giving me
notes
I don't give you notes Pages well wrong
sometimes they're earned what's one food
David I would absolutely never eat
wow that wasn't true no not a gold star
one food that you won't what do I not
like on anything
and raw onion oh I was gonna say onion
egg salad it depends on the egg salad in
my opinion oh what's the biggest dinner
party faux pas not with flowers without
a vase ding ding ding ding flowers
without a face people just bring like a
bouquet of flowers now I'm supposed to
stop what I'm doing and cooking and get
a vase and cut the flowers and put them
out you can't bring a vase with it how
much more time does it take just to put
it in a base glass half full
this one glass half full you got it got
it you got it what is a skill I wish I
had but haven't learned yet uh
woodworking I know how to work with wood
no I can't juggle five balls yet oh
juggling again I can juggle three can
juggle four no problem
five to five pattern oh I can only play
with so many balls
if I could eat one thing for the rest of
my life what would it be probably a
pasta yeah I think that's what I'd say
really yeah good job I thought you
scared to say dick
what is my cocktail order Margaritas
ding negronis gin Negroni ding Manhattan
oh Rose all day ding Ding and one
more
three out of four considering you
haven't had a drink in seven years seven
years I'm impressed by that yeah
oh but I noticed how much you drink next
question what is my favorite character
you've played when we first started
dating I did uh Cabaret at Studio 54 and
I was the MC and I got to go around in
the audience and you were sitting in the
one of those little cocktail tables and
I got to drape myself over you and we
were kind of you were kind of crushing a
little bit and I was a little flirty was
that it yeah I'll give it to you your
characters are long extensive let's go
through them oh God don't okay I don't
want to fight if I were a drag queen
what would my stage name be isn't it you
take your grandma's name and you put the
last dessert you ate for you Eleanor
donut hole
okay what would it be for real for real
for real I would take Gideon's favorite
drag name for you yeah Anita dollar
Anita dala what is my favorite thing you
cook for me Bolognese easy bowling yays
for the win I mean that's not even there
wasn't anything there wasn't even a
pause not even a question this
motherfucker's bowling Ace is off the
chain whether you eat it fresh and it's
just made or if it's been in the fridge
for a day or if it's in Frozen and
reheated by the way you haven't made
Bolognese for me in like months I don't
do enough for you do I
who made the first move
I think it was me I think it was you I
think I made I dropped you off after
that first date no I haven't before that
really uh-huh
there was that like chamber before you
got to the bathroom oh
first move
I had to describe our relationship in
three words
what would they be careful now hilarious
yeah Non-Stop
[Music]
yeah Adventure I'm gonna give you those
three points
all right it's time for the riding
rounds
Harold or Kumar Paramore
coffee or Red Bull coffee desert island
item puzzles oh puzzles is a really good
one I was gonna say one of those
um one of those called those those
keyboards that have a tube that you can
breathe into the tube and you can play
like
desert island items yeah then big
batteries man good cop or bad cop good
cop karaoke song Piano Man
screen or stage screen you didn't even
say a word you just said screen I can't
pick one my kids can't pick one
Disneyland or Disney World one two three
go there's Disney World all day every
day Disneyland is great it's bespoke
don't get me wrong but Disney World is
it's a world compared to a land well
that was fun dude
yeah that was real fun who do you think
won probably me I probably won yep honey
yep final tally I know
oh
I'm used to dimming my life for his life
when I win it's fine when I win we both
win right
foreign